[Music]
all right guys how you doing its
l-boogie oh 208 coming to you demoing
NBA 2k playgrounds 2 for the iron words
podcast Dream Team and I got a full
season done with this game and I have to
say someone who doesn't play basketball
games
it was pretty accessible which I'm happy
for a lot of times the NBA games are
kind of I guess you would say like
off-putting because you feel like it's
too intricate stick work who wants to
lose right so this is a lot more
accessible as combo moves kind of
similar to what you would see in like a
fighting game so it's a little bit
easier to play the rounds I believe are
about three minutes and it's only
two-man teams so it's pretty easy to get
through a season I want to say maybe two
and a half hours
no probably like three three and a half
hours for a full season as you can see I
did not win the season but it was still
pretty awesome pretty fun to play
through it does get harder as you get to
the championship rounds but I wasn't
able to do any of the three point
contests I could do those as far as just
local CPU you versus a CPU what I didn't
like about the three point contest is
you have to use players that you get
through the cards when you get the game
they give you a few players through the
cards but ultimately you have to play
through seasons and whatnot to get
points otherwise you have to purchase
the
do the cards card packs so you only have
those players available to use so if you
have people that aren't necessarily good
at three-point shots then you'll not
have a fun time playing the three-point
exhibition I haven't been able to play
anybody online I don't know if that's
due to any of the what would you say
server issues or if there's no one
really on to play this game online but
that was pretty frustrating I did want
to check out some of the online modes to
be able to see what that was like yeah I
mean the championships any of that stuff
you can't really do because it's all
online so you could do a competitive
game but I haven't been able to do any
of that cooperative I think it was
pretty neat so you're able to play couch
co-op with someone playing the second
player on your team and then three-point
contest so the game is pretty simplified
which makes it accessible but there's
graphical issues they could update it's
definitely probably a game that they're
putting out to see test the waters and
see if people are interested in
purchasing it I wouldn't give it a don't
lie but I guess buy with caution because
if you want to get the players you
really want you're going to have to put
money into it
or a lot of time into completing seasons
right now I have about 8,000 points I've
spent four thousand on one pack so you
figure throughout playing a full season
you're gonna get it roughly twelve to
fifteen thousand points which will help
you get packs but the packs aren't cheap
especially if you're paying with in-game
currency so for a gold pack for in-game
currency is about five thousand points
you figure if you play through a full
season you're going to get three
packs and those packs aren't guaranteed
to give you the players for the teams
that you want each pack has various
players various teams so yeah
so that's a little crappy and then you
can pay to unlock a full roster the
price is 5000 points of actual currency
and to be able to get this currency from
the Xbox or I'm assuming it's gonna be
at least ten bucks for a thousand points
or something like that but yeah I like
the game I enjoyed the game I don't know
how often I will play this game just
because like I said you can't find
online matches easily or at least I
haven't been able to find online matches
easily but yeah I enjoyed it I'm glad I
got to review it and I hope you guys
check out the game alright peace
[Music]
you